latinoamérica a pesar de que no es una
de las regiones del mundo que es
mayormente responsable de las emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero no está
exenta a esos pérdidas y daños y tampoco
creo que es la excusa para justificar
que se retrase la acción climática creo
que tenemos una responsabilidad también
como región y como ciudadanía de que
cada peso que se invierten nuestros
países esté encaminado a reducir
emisiones está encaminado a reducir la
vulnerabilidad que tienen los sistemas
ecológicos y los sistemas humanos frente
al cambio climático creo que parte de
esa representación va a ser que podamos
canalizar las voces territoriales las
voces de las mujeres las voces de las
poblaciones étnicas indígenas
afrodescendientes campesinas que ya
sufren del cambio climático y que se ven
afectados cierto tiene equitativamente
entonces nuestro rol tiene que ser
empujar un liderazgo transformador para
la acción climática